you know we're family and that's our
model in the end we always figure it out
even if we're not loving each other at
that moment we always love each other
tony braxton breaks her silence
following her sister tamar braxton's
hospitalization
i'm the oldest so you know i'm the one
that kind of try to puts it all together
all the time
but we just love each other we fight
hard i mean really hard but we love him
on wednesday the 52-year-old entertainer
took to instagram to share this pic with
her sisters
the unbreak my heart singer captioned
the throwback pic
family is everything especially sisters
the comments section quickly flooded
with well wishes for tamar and her
family
tony's post comes almost a week after
tony and tamar's sisters tawanda
tracy and trina posted messages of hope
on instagram following tamar's
hospitalization
on july 16th what's the emergency
my girlfriend is not responding are you
with her right now
yes according to multiple reports the
braxton family values star was found
unresponsive by her boyfriend david
adefaso at the ritz-carlton residences
in downtown los angeles where they were
staying
we're on the way um i'm gonna stay on
the line okay he's been drinking
it's like a halfway uh she's on
medication for depression i don't know
how much
she sent a letter earlier anyway just
ask him to hurry
the blast reports that tamar has since
been transferred to a hospital facility
in la
to receive more specialized mental
health treatment from top experts
on july 23 david gave an update on
tamar's condition
thanking people for their thoughts and
prayers as she navigates professional
and personal struggles including her
battle with depression
quote tamar is currently receiving the
best available medical attention
to address those struggles and
strengthen her mental health
and her family and i will remain by her
side throughout her treatment
it just goes to show you how resilient
we all are when we have to figure it out
we figure it out e.t caught up with
tamar in may where she shared how she
was keeping in contact with her family
as they separately quarantined amid the
coronavirus pandemic
we get together and zoom and facetime
all the time
and that's been pretty fun i haven't
seen my mom um
in three months and that's been really
really tough and while she said she had
seen
some of her family in person she noticed
she couldn't get
too close to big sis tony because of the
grammy winners battle with lupus which
puts her at high risk for covert 19.
we've really had a really good time and
you know getting closer and talking
about things that
you know that needs to be talked about
before we start filming again
tamar added that she hopes the pandemic
continued to put things in perspective
for her and her sisters
and she wants to keep it positive on the
show i'm just ready to move on with the
next chapter of my life that's what i
mean
back in 2019 et spoke with the braxton
sisters
about moving past their problems and
putting their family first
i'm just really glad that everybody's in
a better place we're just trying to
respect each other's boundaries and just
you know try to work along with each
other
because everybody has differences of
what they want in business
we're still still a work in progress you
know um we're working every day
to get better every day and i just think
that one thing that i've pulled from
this situation
is everything is about everything in
life is about a choice
everything in life either you're going
to be sad or happy so i'm making a
choice to be happy
today